welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in earlier this summer it was announced
that conor mcgregor would be taking his
talents to the silver screen being
casted in the upcoming reboot of the
cult classic roadhouse the film starring
jake gyllenhaal is set to shoot in the
dominican republic which raised
questions of how the project could
possibly affect mcgregor's return to the
octagon mcgregor's manager tim simpson
cleared the air during a recent sit down
with mma junkie he's still on track for
a big return next year but this fits
perfectly in the meantime the leg is
still healing i think there's a little
bit more to go on that but he's been
training like a madman twice a day every
day he's got his full team out there the
mcgregor fast team all his health and
fitness guys physio boxing coaching he's
been going hard he's been training super
hard he's in amazing shape just final
adjustments to get that leg back to
where it needs to be in a recent
interview with tmz former welterweight
champion camaro usman spoke about his
shocking loss to leon edwards last
saturday usman gave edwards duke credit
for his head kick knockout with less
than a minute left but doesn't want
people to forget he was controlling the
fight up to that point it was it was
just a what a shot it was a great shot a
great shot i'm talking
hail mary to the super bowl
in the super bowl last 10 seconds that's
a great that was a great shot man
i've watched it fight now what three
four times four times watched it once
yesterday i've watched it three times
this morning today
the four times no it's not hard at all
you know how many people i've done that
to
you know and
it's not hard at all it happened like
that's the thing that's the beautiful
thing about this sport is
that happens but we forget what was
actually taking place in that fight
so i'm not down at all you know it's
almost like everyone's more
everyone is more sad about it than i am
you know everyone's more emotional about
it than i am
but that's because um you know for me
it's a good thing because it lets me
know that people care people are the
best usman then went on the share he is
planning on challenging edwards for the
belt and already has a date and location
in mind i'm just excited uh i'm excited
for for what what's next
i'm in a rare opportunity i
have a rare opportunity now to
to just inspire and motivate and show
people that uh you can
you can follow and get back up so yeah
i'm excited about that i mean what
what else makes sense
i mean look at the division you know
it's like yeah what else makes sense no
it's absolutely what's gonna happen next
uh
uh talk to dana um and
we're gonna see uh you know let him do
his job and
we're going to see what what date makes
sense it's going to be top of next year
um i was going to try to squeeze one in
this year you know
but uh
you know it'd probably be top of next
year and i want to go to england
yeah i've been i've been feeding to go
to england
you know
like that's that's i feel like england
is my second home i i've been shocked
you know england is half africa
you know people don't know that but it's
half africa
so uh
you know it's time to go over there and
entertain my english people and uh what
better story i mean like you couldn't
write this any better staying at the top
of the welterweight division contender
gilbert burns spoke with the all-star
about his potential next fight according
to burns two names he's looking at are
colby covington and jorge monsvidal but
that any fight with covington would have
to wait until 2023. burns revealed that
covington is still dealing with serious
injuries that were inflicted by mazvidal
outside of a miami steakhouse earlier
this year the rumors were that he was
very bad he had a neck injury the nerves
were very bad he lost a little bit of
movement in his neck he kind of broke
his jaw again he had surgery and the
surgery didn't go well he's still doing
the pt he's not training if everything
goes okay he's only back in march that's
what i heard i don't know if it's true
but i heard from guys that know him i
think it's true because he's been quiet
he hasn't said anything i think he's out
until march next year even with
covington out burns was able to make a
road map for his next couple of fights
colby is always an option you know if
you're asking me what's the best option
for me i'd say moz vidal in december or
january and colby next after that
one championship returns this friday in
a brand new way friday's card featuring
a flyweight title rematch between
adriano marias and demetrius johnson
will be one's first event on amazon
prime video the deal between one and
prime will make the streaming giant the
exclusive carrier of one events in north
america the main card will begin
streaming on friday at 10 pm eastern 12
time world champion demetrius johnson
makes his much anticipated debut at one
championship
[Applause]
champion
well obviously on the network i got a
date with adrian marias a world title
showdown for the flyweight gold
well adriano said demetrius was
dominating ufc i was dominating one
championship
dj's
[Applause]
everybody knows who is the best in this
division
if you know you know if you didn't you
know now
okay what i can take a knee to the jaw
get right back up
the rematch we've all been waiting for
one on prime video one will also feature
british muay thai fighter jonathan
hagerty the former flyweight muay thai
world champion is looking to work his
way back into the flyweight world grand
prix hagerty initially withdrew from the
bracket due to medical issues but will
have an opportunity to secure an
alternate spot on friday when he faces
amir nasari despite training in muay
thai since the age of 8 and teaching
classes out of his father's gym hagerty
sees a future for himself in mma
according to hagerty that transition
will begin after the flyweight grand
prix looking for more original mma
content check out the rest of thick boy
youtube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shob show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action